servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker show wie
immer zeig ich euch auch diese woche die
lustigsten fünf hacker der letzten woche
wir fangen an mit einer 1 sendung in der
es nicht um den hacker geht es nicht
platz eins das ist wie man so ein
kleiner vorgeschmack ein kleiner
appetizer für die eigentlich ein 5 1
sendung was einfach so passiert wenn
leute nicht so ganz darauf klar kommen
dass mit major runde sind seht ihr hier
die einsendung stammen von dani und er
spielt super six turnier hat mit seinem
kollegen da etwas am start und spielten
zwei hacker hat schon eine runde gegen
die gespielt und später noch mal ne
runde gegen die wohlgemerkt beide
gegnerischen spieler sind hacker und
dann gebt euch das
okay gut ja soviel hierzu wenn er in der
nächsten folge dabei sein wollt ihr bist
wahrscheinlich wie es geht wir nehmen
wie im material von einem hacker lade
das als ungelöste das video auf youtube
hoch und schickt mir den link zu diesem
um gelisteten video per privater youtube
nachricht ok damit springen wir jetzt zu
platz numero für platz 5 stammt von pb
dp und hacker in baku es dass es
offensichtlich ein spielmodus auf kein
leben punkt netz von mir schon mal was
nutzer geschickt hat der p g data
alltäglich ist würdig seien alltäglich
ist was sieht man ja dass so ohne witz
was hat man nicht alles schon gesehen im
rahmen dieser hacker schau ich hatte
letztens kein scheiß einfach der
einsendung da es deckt sind hoch und
fliegt damit gleich hektisch die gegend
wo ich dachte mir so ein moment mal
wusste heck wo ist defekt ist so ein
hacker schon sendung sein und letzten
endes habe ich einfach den hack gar
nicht mehr gesehen
man sieht sie für hacker einsendung man
sieht tatsächlich so viele hacker
einsendung was man teilweise gar nicht
merkt dass leute heckt okay aber er
jetzt wunderbar kläglich die gegend mit
dem grünen erinnert also ein bisschen an
peter pan der name lässt auch erkennen
dass er für immer jung bleiben möchte
für immer zehn jahre alt er hat noch
einen gegner als klein diese komischen
runde back wars wo sich alles muss
packen dreht und da ist ein letzter
gegner roma geht ihr gut tucker du
kannst es schaffen
oder halt auch nicht so jetzt war kurz
revisited
da baut er ich weiß gar nicht was müssen
wir den modus ab in den ofen ist der
ofen ist alles da da fliegt air fliegt
er heute erstmal weg aus dem leben
heraus box hinaus seien latschen
fehlt dann ihr überhaupt den weg kommt
dass sie gerade noch überhaupt kommen
alle bauen der continuo klatsche weg ein
hier ist das gleiche prinzip überall war
was sagst du dazu nba kannst du
weitergeben leute platz 4 stammt von
zocker style und obwohl der gute mann
nicht auf einer kartoffel aufgenommen
hat wie man sie erkennen kann so
qualität passt sein aber leider schwarze
rennen am rand ist immer so also wenn
ihr könnt
vermeide auf jeden fall schwarze ränder
und kartoffelauflauf alles klar geht
auch wieder aus dem backes oder steht
das kann der luft
wunderbar wir einfach mit seinen
häcksler kommt der typ ist vollkommen
überfordert also jetzt moment ich sollte
eigentlich nie in der luft stehen sagt
zurück besteht wieder der luft und dann
irgendwann nachdem als 30 sekunden darum
gammelt im heck auf einmal ach ja ich
könnte ja mein hexte für einsätze
irgendwie auch nicht zu falten
er wird gekillt merkte dass und nachdem
man endlich herausgefunden wie man nur
nach vorne fliegt wird einfach hier
klatsch 321 zack weg bitter also ich
will jetzt nicht sagen dass er hätte
rein machen sollen natürlich soll er
klar nicht reinmachen aber dass sie da
ist auch schon bitter alter verkäufer so
getötet mann
platz 3 stammt von gross thrashers die
haben uns ziemlich schöne einsendung
mitgegeben und zwar ist die bet awards
hacker goma hd profi hacker alles klar
was soll mit dem profi kader vorstellen
30 jahre berufserfahrung hatte 30 jahre
berufserfahrung
30 jahre ist schon am hacken minecraft
obwohl es minecraft erst seit ich weiß
nicht vielleicht mal kopf gibt okay gut
shell will wissen wie ein profi hacker
aussieht und die broncos thrashers jungs
können es uns jetzt erzählen alles
klappt haben wir so einen typen der
natürlich alles klar
alles klar der irgendwie nicht so bock
hat gerade ihr unter gestanden zu werden
absolut die note schill und bei er
wieder auch nur einen hack hat also weg
gehörte der trend geht hin zum einen zum
einen hacker zum einzelnen heck die
leute wollen mehrere hexenagger benutzt
den zu viel ihr wollt schön einfach
halten immer noch ein hammer und er
benutzt notfall oder so kommt nicht
weiter mit die eiskappe klatscht aber
ganz witzig zu sehen auf jeden fall wo
hier der unter box man denkt sich so
jetzt haben wir jetzt ein medikament
erhalten links und rechts die ganze zeit
runter fliegt und sich die ganze
wiederholt und dann einfach hier weg
klatsch wird vom typen komplett ohne
rüstung mit der faust getötet bitter
alter
sole platz 2 stammt von ml water und er
nennt das video all caps heftiger
speaker hacker drei ausrufezeichen
debatte org apps müssen wir nicht so
voll ist ein heftiger
ich weiß ist schon blöd genug aus dass
ich in meinem pc sitzen einfach durch
die gegend schreie aber es wird noch
blöder wenn man bedenkt ist es einfach
jetzt zwei uhr nachts ist ja okay gut
ihr tv wie wir uns in hacker anschauen
kommen platz 24 okay er steht ja
irgendwo oben besteht um 3 auf 1000
irgendwas nicht ohne job so oder so was
gar nicht so ligety ja alter was talking
wieder dieses video wurde dich mit einer
kartoffel aufgenommen aber leute ich
kann euch sagen dass not plugin dieser
service besteht definitiv aus einem sack
kartoffeln wie kann sowas auf einem
server möglich sein wo auch nur eine
person einen gedanken daran verschwendet
kita kind zu installieren der typ ist
vollkommen außer kontrolle
das nicht zu retten so dort steht er
jettet da wir wirklich die gegend also
dass mobiles einfach dass wenn man so
was nicht keine ahnung und dann auf
einmal da oben pam pam mace wir im in
der luft hinterher reist ja also ich
schlecht in einem mal runter und fliegt
ihm hinterher und gibt ihm in der luft
doch wieviel schläge drei vier schläge
hatte ok ich selber die schläge mit ja
erster schlag zweiter schlag in der luft
dritter schlag in der luft vierter
schlag in der luft also ergibt dem
mindestens drei schläge während der
andere durch die luft fliegt fliegt
hinterher so ich mag es eigentlich leute
seine kommentaren diskutieren ob es eine
einsendung glitschig war oder nicht
in dem fall ist es relativ eindeutig
würde ich sagen
platz eins stammt habe ich auf meinem
bildschirm angespuckt platz eins stammt
von moabit und heißt hacker auf das
ultra range okay man was ist los mit mir
mal nicht spurt bei monitoren praktisch
schweine geräusch grund ins mikrofon
beck auf das ultra range von noah b film
ab ist es niki lauda ist es irgendwas
ist es eine laugenbrezel man weiß es
nicht
in der stadt rom gestartet okay wir sind
darunter
wer von wert von 4 wird seine hacken der
der grüne
der gelbe der rote oder der blaue er hat
irgendwie so den grünen bis in den blick
habe ich gefühl verdächtig warum sind
die ganze zeit darüber
ok alles klar
sieht ganz so aus als würde grünen
einfach mal wieder schön freaky mäßig
aus der base heraus einfach diverse okay
leute alles klar
wunderschön wie dieser typ einfach
eiskalt nach 30 sekunden wenn es
überhaupt 30 sekunden waren 30 sekunden
in der runde ja die leute möchte einfach
nur spielen wie auch immer dieser
spielmodus heißt kriegt etwas da habe
ich kugel steht landwirt möchte einfach
nur krieg etwas spielen ja und da kommt
so eine voll banane und baut einfach
innerhalb von 30 sekunden auf seinen
eigenen base heraus alle anderen blöcke
warum warum wollte seine pace ein
wahrscheinlich woanders liegen kann ein
killer im november das geläute leute was
meint ihr wie geht die runde aus wie
könnte diese runde ausgehen der typ
einfach sein eigenes heraus indem er die
luft schlägt halle abgebaut hat könnte
er diese runde eventuell gewinnen
experten sind sich noch uneinig darüber
wie dieser verlaufen könnte
was macht er jetzt da stehst du ganz
ganz schlecht da stehst du irgendwie
nicht so gut
ja und jetzt alles klar oder dream liegt
auch noch einer und dessen zweck holen
das wetter noch eine per zieht die einer
parodie einer perle fliegt die fig flieg
flieg wichtig oder andere kilo wen
überrascht es eigentlich noch zu diesem
zeitpunkt das hätte ich keine kinder
hatte by the way ist der gute alte 100
blöcke range extender wiederbelebt wurde
kelm kleines revival macht da seht was
er hat einfach die luft zack zack zack
und miri spa blöcke verschwinden es ist
einfach ein kompletter cluster [ __ ]
alter komplett 360 das war's mit dieser
woche hacker schau dieser folge diesen
sonntag auf sehr leicht gefallen wenn ja
dann lass gern like da und schickt
material ein
und seit cool